mais juste avant c'est un petit mot sur
les stars d'abord les stars qui chante
les stars qui sont très présentes en
russie et qui aujourd'hui évidemment
sont très très rares sur des réseaux
sociaux déclarent les top des stars qui
sont très très très célèbre en russie
dans le top 20 il ya déjà il ya jazz the
way tout de suite on à stromae ouais on
à mylène farmer absolument oui on à
mireille mathieu un match ça c'est déjà
le top après il ya patricia kaas qui est
une icône là bas mais l'absolu ouais et
on a eu après d'aidé alors je vais pas
remonter jusqu'en 1956 avec yves montand
qui était le premier artiste à première
star a déchanté en urss à l'époque et
c'était c'était surprenant que c'était
fermé totalement à l'occident mais
c'était dans un combat militant
politique évidemment et il a hésité
parce que les chars russes en 1956 le 23
octobre ils avaient envahi budapest la
hongrie mais il a hésité à les chanter
il a eu un entretien que le président de
l'époque cette palette khrouchtchev de
khrouchtchev par mon propre chef et ça a
duré quatre heures et mon temps il
reprend très déçu finalement du
communisme lui qui était à seulement
adhérents du pont communiste français il
avait cet aperçu que le communisme en
urss n'était plus tout le même renault
qui a chanté aussi la barre à moscou
c'était le 30 juillet 1985 toutes les
dates du temps non mais c'est quand même
formidable parce que renault lui aussi
avait invité par le parti communiste
français
pour le parti communiste soviétique au
moment où il a chanté la chanson qui
s'appelle déserteurs un moment donné
dans la chanson il ya une phrase qui dit
quand les russes les ricains font péter
la planète moi je re l'air malin avec
mam avec ma sur la bicyclette hélas le
savez que pour que renault allait
chanter en russie il fallait qu'ils
donnent tous les textes de ses chansons
on est en 1985 déjà cité gorbatchev
incroyable à l'époque le président donc
ça toujours été quand même très contrôlé
un tu saurais vous dire quand même c'est
que aujourd'hui je vois par exemple que
zaz on en parlait bella elle a soutenu
ont volé les l'insta elle a soutenu ne
s'est pas positionné elle a soutenu les
deux peuples mais on le voit par exemple
mais non mais pas sans celle qu'elle
gagne
c'est le monde et la paix c'est parce
que voilà non mais non mais c'est à dire
qu'il faut pas mal je pense
oui
par de pardieu il a dit la russie doit
arrêter de la russie et l'ukraine
doivent arrêter la guerre et négocier ya
un moment où on fait tout c'est pas la
russie et l'ukraine qui font la guerre
c'est la russie subit en russie a pas
deux maisons qui sont détruites y a pas
d'enfants qui meurent en l'air c'est en
espagne que ça c'est quoi m en même
temps moi je déjeune chez eux aussi ont
la faune sur instagram j'aimerais
beaucoup pour tendu et alors ils ont
beaucoup au kremlin oui mais moi j'y
réfléchis oui ou non elle n'a pas chanté
au kremlin je vais où je descends qui
sont venus dans des concerts publics
elle n'a jamais fait alors mais elle a
toujours refusé c'est pas parce qu'on
chante non plus en russie condé pro
poutine ou autres au gouvernement non
médias ce qui seront se positionne pas
côté and gertz bien sûr de dire aussi
qu'on ne veut pas moi je comprends pas
en laine farmer qui a déjà signé pour
août et septembre 2023 avec son nouveau
spectacle qu'elle va donner en france
d'ailleurs au printemps trois aussi bon
à un moment donné les contrats sont
signés on fait très attention on n'est
pas vue d'un contrat ce
genre dans le même cas qui cassent hors
contrat donc en fait faut simplement
dire qu'il y en a qui le font pas et en
a qui louent mais puisqu'on parle de
contrat alors que ça ne part jamais
d'argent en vrai dans tout ça moi je
suis une époque où les prix ne l'avait
prenait 100 ou 150 mille euros pour
aller passer une soirée au kremlin où
elle est invitée à trieste à dire que je
connais rien à l'économie personnel
gérard depardieu et je faire extrêmement
attention la revoir à l'édifice et mais
il ya les rapports de free en savate
150000 euros et tu as raison de le
rappeler cent cinquante mille euros à 1
million d'euros selon si on fait deux
concerts à saint pétersbourg à moscou ou
si on fait comme lara fabian en 2013
elle a fait une tournée de 25 dates dans
toute la russie elle avait vendu 400
mille albums mais faut savoir par
exemple les droits d'auteur en russie
c'est rien pratiquement rien par rapport
à la france c'est à dire que y'a et
quant à la en 91 quand ils ont divisé
l'urss qui est devenue la russie où il
ya la fois 15 application du droit dans
les quinze états qui ce qu'il avait
quitté la russie donc c'est très
compliqué donc en gagnent beaucoup
d'argent ce sont les concerts mais oui
ça vous choque pas vous je ne prends pas
position
s'appelle fabrice bien
je pense que pour faire un petit montage
savoureux coûter près d'écoles étaient
petits trucs ici n'était pas présente et
vous comment mcdo vous avez un nom ici
vous êtes amoureux dans son garage il
annexe qui s'appelait fabien
alors mylène c'est bien son prénom par
ailleurs je sais bien qu'il ya un gros
contrat d'aujourd'hui qui ne dit pas un
mot alors qu'on est à plus de 6000 fans
ne sais pas combien de morts les morts
c'est compliqué de les compter ce qui
est de la propagande n'en sais pas
peut-être que 10000 morts aujourd'hui
parce qu'alain contrat le dit pas un mot
ça choque personne mais en même temps
elle a vacillé la seaal a pas signé son
contrat avec le kremlin ni poutine oui
mais quand même non non mais bien dorées
en plus non mais non mais
les gens bien mais je suis bien placé
pour savoir que mylène farmer elle est
reçue comme une reine en russie là bas
je suis bien mais c'est pas je peux pas
vous dire à tous ses membres de file je
suis très bien placé pour vous le dire
et on sait également qu'elle fait partie
de ceux qui ont su y ait des contrats
astronomiques quand ils sont reçus en
russie allait reçu comme la reine
d'angleterre dans des suites mais des
choses rocambolesque et donc
effectivement le fait qu'elle ne se
positionne pas c'est tout simplement
pour pas perdre de l'oseille ils sont
pas brouiller aussi avec oui il a bien
su alors que l'envié du préparateur des
choeurs de l'armée rouge voilà qui est
de montpellier rick plus connus du rss
voilà qui se produit partout dans mon
malheur concert vient d'être annulée que
les producteurs a dessiné
par dieu tout à l'heure en fait on parle
d'argent pardonnez moi aussi parlé de
courage et et il est aussi question
d'avoir des coûts c'est à dire
franchement pierre richard qu'une
immense star en russie qui a reçu
exactement comme mylène farmer quand il
y va c'est comme gérard depardieu et ben
il s'est pas mouillé il a dit baisser
les armes et négocier bah oui ou non on
ne sait pas c'est pas négocier qu'il
faut c'est prendre parti dire les choses
dire ce qu'on pense tout bas noirs alors
à d'aller mouiller oui et d'ailleurs le
1 100 rappeur super connue en russie que
c'est à guichet complet total qui a
annulé tous ses concerts en soutien pour
rien et ce sont des rapa nui pardon je
pense qu'il faut faire du cas par cas
selon les a reprises parce que nous
sommes tous n'ont pas le même succès
les mêmes tout le monde ils ont tous été
star une période donnée dans leur
carrière moi je défends les artistes
parce que à ce moment là il ya d'autres
artistes qui vont chanter dans des pays
en guerre souvent ça arrive sur c'est
pas pour ça qu'on prend un engagement
politique connaissant bien les artistes
je rejoins là où je vous rejoins c'est
évidemment faux étonné de tout la table
demain on vous dit il ya quatre millions
d'euros à gagner si tu m'épates oui non
non est ce que tous de
l'écologie ces machins les fromages
c'est pas un sac de 4 millions d'euros
et études positionne contre la russie
mais je vais faire un concert en russie
en léchant
croit
tous les pays européens il met là des
choses en place pour enfermer un petit
peu la russie et l'isoler et puis les
artistes ibrahim en fait plus pour achat
qui vont venir sur des toiles avoue
malgré tout amérique ulation alors
effectivement très bien pu mesurer non
mais toujours mais vraiment une immense
star en russie ça fait depuis 1967
qu'elle chante en russie en ukraine au
bout elle est passionnée par ces deux
peuples et désespéré le passons tant
pleuré en ce moment elle ce que les
médias qu'il appelle ses pour la
flinguer soyons commercialement je fais
partie des gens qui scelle me demander
mon avis il reste surtout n'y va pas
parce que autant les autres surtout un
depardieu on ne pose vraiment la
question pensent que c'est mireille
c'est pour la flinguer alors que mène au
téléphone et elle peut répondre à dire
oui effectivement ce que fait la russie
c'est mal mais alors elle dit ll n'y
bien évidemment qu'elle dit c'est
terrible ce qui arrive aux ukrainiens
elle leur semble qu'on fait c'est pas
toi chérie de la presse sana qui je suis
pour mais pour évoquer syrie m
un tout petit mois purement simon
président ukrainien ou quand une grosse
différence à faire entre des gens qui
chantent qui vont se produire sur des
scènes et des gens comme pardon gérard
depardieu qui affichent un soutien
pour beauty on n'est pas
au oui mais jean mi il a dit le jour du
démarrage de la guerre il a dit
désormais j habitais de zai et je suis
russe c'est vraiment franchement c'est
une provocation mais je voulais répondre
à hugo parce que aya ferait vraiment pas
tant d'encre et je vais faire quoi il ya
une hypocrisie parce que l'allemagne n'a
toujours pas coupé son
les fournitures de gaz avec la russie et
le switch non plus un pour être payé 800
millions